- Terry Crews.
(hip hop music)
(audience cheering)
(applause)
(audience cheers)
- Yes.
- Looks good, huh?
(Terry laughs)
- That never gets old, buddy.
- It never gets old.
- That never gets old.
You think that's amazing that his--
You got talent.
I--
Not only that.
(Terry cackles)
I just talked about this just for--
I'll just start off and then
we'll talk about other things.
But, you always do the flexing.
You always do that flexing, right?
- Always. Always.
- And I noticed at work, at AGT,
you taught Simon how to do it.
- Yes.
- You taught Heidi how to do it.
Heidi is really good, actually.
- She tells that me she can do it.
I'm not allowed to see whether she can.
- No, we've never seen it.
- Her eyes are here.
- We've never seen it.
- I've never have seen it.
- But she's really good.
But, I--
How did you teach them and
why did you teach them?
= Because it's such an attention getter.
And you gotta understand,
the older I get, the better it's gonna be
because they're like, they get saggy.
And then they just start to
fly up a little bit more.
So, it's gonna be good.
But all you have to do,
and this is the technique.
And anybody in the world can do it.
Just hold--
If you put your hands together,
- All right.
- And you just squeeze.
- Oh look, the l--
- Squeeze.
- Everybody.
- Squeeze your hands
together and you can feel.
- Wow, that's amazing.
- It's moving.
- That's a real--
- And you know what?
- See, now everybody's got talent.
- The way I started and
learned how to do that
is because I was really lonely and I had--
- No.
(audience laughs)
- I'm not kidding, I
was like 12 years old.
- Yeah.
- There was no dates.
I was sitting at home alone.
I was looking in the
mirror and I was like,
"Oh, oh wow."
You know, 12 year old boys come up with
some really ridiculous things.
- Right.
When your only friends
are your two nipples.
That is,
(Terry laughs hysterically)
that is really lonely.